Lee: Extraordinary people doing
extraordinary things.
By the end of
a 21-day excavation
we had discovered the
richest early Hominid site
ever discovered in the
history of the planet.
This site is one mile away
from the site of Sterkfontein.
It's less than
half that distance
from the second best known site
in the entire
continent of Africa
the site of Swartkrans,
800 meters away.
It was right under our nose.
It was an incredible
environment of science.
There, we had a fossil tent
where we kept joking that
we need a bigger safe
and we had to buy more boxes
and more bags than
we ever envisioned.
We'd set up a thing to
find a skeleton
and we had, first,
hundreds of remains
and by the end of it, thousands
of remains of hominids.
We would work late
into the night.
I, sometimes couldn't get the
scientists out of the cave
as they excavated for
shifts of six or seven hours
in these cramped,
humid conditions.
And no one could
go get them anyway
so they could just stay there
as long as they wanted.
( audience laughter )
Some people have said, "Well, it
really isn't that dangerous."
Rick is going to demonstrate
to you, though that
just because we
did not kill anyone
that this is
every bit as dangerous
and extraordinary a risk
as has ever been undertaken.
These are the easy parts
you're looking at.
This was an original thing
we called "Superman Crawl"
which you go through.
I can get through that.
So, that's not a
particularly tight squeeze
in the scheme of what
we're doing here.
For those of you who are
squeamish about closed spaces
you may look away,
because it gets worse.
This is the type of journey that
these remarkable scientists
the runners,
the people who assisted us
would take on a daily basis
usually three, four,
five times a day,
getting to these sites.
Some people said to me
"Why haven't you
opened this cave up?"
I hope you can begin to see,
how fragile this cave is.
You do not want to do
any opening of caves
in that environment
because if you do, you may
destabilize the entire system
and it could collapse.
And secondly, I didn't
want to do that.
Who was it for me
to destroy a cave
that's potentially
millions of years old
just so it could be large enough
that my ego could get in there
when there is technology
and extraordinary people
who have the capability
of doing that work today.
Here, this is kind of a normal,
narrow passage.
You're going to see the chute
and parts of it here.
And you'll get an
idea of the depth
as you see Steve Tucker's
light in the distance
as we look down into the chute
and you get an idea of how
narrow those spaces are
that they are traversing down.
You'll see how dangerous
some of those loose rocks are.
This rock that Rick
is about to touch
actually fell on a National
Geographic Photographer
and shattered his fingers,
as he was under there.
Oh and... Rick can dislocate
his shoulders. Watch.
I just showed you that for fun.
( audience laughter )
Extraordinary people doing
extraordinary things.
By the end of a
a 21-day excavation
we had discovered the
richest early hominid site
ever discovered in the
history of the planet.
More fossil hominids had
come out individually
than had been discovered in
the previous 90 year history
of the search for human
origins in Southern Africa.
All because of these
remarkable scientists.
We would name
a new species, "Homo naledi".
Homo naledi was an
incredible creature.
A brain, the size of an orange
primitive characters and
advanced characters
teeth that are remarkable in
being a little bit human-like
and then primitive in
so many other ways.
Things we'd never seen before.
We would eventually
find 15 individuals.
One thousand, five hundred
and seventy four fossils.
From an area,
that big by that big.
The entire floor is
comprised of these fossils.
We had every age
group represented.
From near fetal aged infants
to the extreme elderly with
their teeth worn right out
and everything in between,
males and females.
We had fossils like this
field has never seen before.
That is the most complete foot
ever discovered in the history
of paleoanthropology.
One of six.
This is the most complete hand
ever discovered in the history
of paleoanthropology.
One of eight.
The assemblage was remarkable.
Remarkable in its diversity,
remarkable in its preservation
remarkable in its quality.
We simply had seen
nothing like it.
All lying on the floor
of this chamber.
We would name a new species,
"Homo naledi".
It's a crazy creature.
Brain, the size of an
orange, ape-like shoulders
human-like arms ending
in a human-like hand
with the most curved
fingers we have ever seen
outside the most
primitive hominids.
Four or five million
year old equivalents.
It's bizarre.
It's thorax, starts ape-like,
becomes more and more advanced.
It's pelvis is like that
of Lucy, wide and flared.
So, we know what its
legs and feet look like.
They should be primitive too
but they are at the top and
become progressively more and
more and more human-like
until you reach the feet.
And those are the most
human-like feet ever discovered
since humans.
Look at the size of that head.
That is a normal sized, modern
human in the background.
That is an adult female
of Homo naledi.
About 450 cubic centimeters.
We had truly never seen
anything like this.
To give you an idea of how
strange they would've looked.
That's Lucy on the left, in the
middle is a very famous skeleton
called, "Turkana Boy"
of Homo Erectus.
And there, you can see a
relatively human-like visage.
There on the right, is that
almost, without being derogatory
pin-headed look of Homo naledi,
with its very strange profile.
And it is not an aberrancy
because we have
multiple individuals
and they all look exactly alike.
We now know more about this
remarkable species, perhaps
than almost any other species
of primitive human relative
that's ever been discovered.
We, very quickly realized,
something was--
strange going on
with the way in which these
fossils were in that chamber.
During the course
of the excavation
we had found on the first day
to be transparent,
three bird bones.
That were owl,
that were lying on the surface.
They were clearly much younger.
Some owl had got in there.
And then we found, during the
course of the excavation
a few, tiny, rodent incisors,
mixed into the sediment.
And nothing else.
Nothing but hominids.
Now, we had on the team
world experts in many,
many different things.
But, all of us had the
same basic training
in physical anthropology,
forensic anthropology
archeology, all related
to human biology.
And those senior members
of the team knew
that there was something
very strange from word go
when you see an
assemblage like that.
We, of course, began trying
to eliminate the obvious.
It's gotta be a
predator accumulation.
But there are no predatory--
marks of damage
on any of this bone.
There's no marks of scavenging.
We knew, very early on
that the material had not
been transported in.
There was no sign in the
sediments of water transport.
We also could tell from
the way they were set
that they'd come in one
by one by one, over time.
There was time involved in this.
Over on the right hand
side of this image
is where that chute is.
You can see that the floor
slopes away from that
and quite literally, from that
point all the way to the end
are these bones of Homo naledi.
Literally, from
underneath the chute.
We have used, I can tell you
ground penetrating radar
and other methods.
We can find no other entrance.
And we were left, eventually,
with the unlikely conclusion
that in fact, this
must be some sort of
deliberate body disposal site.
That we had, for the first time
found a species
other than humans
that in a ritualized, and
I mean, repeated fashion
had taken it's dead
into a chamber
and secreted them
there over time to
prevent whatever from happening
to them for whatever reason.
And that is the hypothesis
we put forward.
That's a fairly
remarkable thing.
Because, until that moment,
on September 10th last year
when we announced the
existence of Homo naledi
and this situation...
we had seen
deliberate body disposal
as sort of the last bastion of
what identified us as human.
When Jane Goodall wrote
to Louis Leakey saying
"I have seen a
chimpanzee using tools."
He said, prophetically
"We're going to have to redefine
what it means to be human."
We had precious little left
until September 10th
except, we deliberately
disposed of our dead
and whatever that means.
And should this
hypothesis hold true
for the first time in history
you are meeting another
species that did just that.
What these discoveries
tell you is that
we may have walked or set
foot over most of this planet
but we have not seen
what we were walking on.
We've not understood
what we were looking at.
There are extraordinary
things to be found.
And if it is true in a field
like paleoanthropology
then it must be true in
every field of science.
We need to use
discoveries like this
to inspire this and the next
generation to be explorers.
To get out in the field.
To look, to prepare yourself
to make discoveries
to use the technology
to inform you,
but to physically go out and
make those discoveries.
We need, ladies and gentlemen,
to inspire exploration.
Thank you very much.
( audience applause )